this is a production of cornell
university
thank you ruth for the introduction as
mentioned i'll be talking about cassava
brown strike disease
and just to let you know that cassava
feeds about 800 million people in the
world
most of whom are in africa but yield
potential has never been attained likely
due to viral diseases like cassava
mosaic disease and cassava
brown straight disease so today my area
of concentration will be cassava brown
straight disease
and i will refer to it as cbsd
throughout the presentation
so i'll talk about cbsd viruta root
necrosis and image analysis using the
phenol apps
g was and a sneak peek into the results
so cassava brown stroke disease is a
positive sense single-stranded rna virus
that belongs to the family put viridae
and we have two species of this virus
the cassava bronze check virus and the
uganda cassava brown strip virus
both viruses are spread by movement of
systemically infected stem cuttings
and are also vectored by white flies
so phytosanitary interventions have been
used to mitigate
uh the effects of this disease but we
believe that deployment of resistant
material
is the most sustainable option to
evaluate this disease
a one to five visual scoring method is
used
and a score of one means the there are
no observable symptoms while a score of
five
means uh these are the most symptoms so
the severity is high
this method is quick and suitable for
field assessment
so so many studies have been conducted
to try and understand the genetic
resistance of cbsd
but i'll talk about the most recent
study from 2018
by ismael kayondo where they conducted
genome-wide association mapping
and genomics prediction for cassava
brown strike disease
in this study they found that at three
months after planting
when asserting the the foliar symptoms
uh
significant peaks were were detected on
chromosome 11
and at six months after planting
significant peaks were detected on
chromosome
uh four uh 11 and 12.
now zooming into chromosome 11 they
discovered that
uh this is actually a nucleotide binding
lucerin rich repeat which plays a
crucial role in disease resistance
but they also noted that uh expression
of uh significant picks on chromosome 11
across environments were not stable uh
the authors of this paper later
concluded that cbsd is polygenic and
unstable across
environments so to expand on these
findings from this paper
my research aims to provide a
comprehensive study
to uncover the genetic architecture of
cbsd by complementing the
one to five scoring scale with improved
phenotyping methods like viral titer
and image analysis so there are four i
will be standardizing the triple
sandwich ant body elisa
to expand on its sensitivity for high
throughput tighter quantification
the question that you'd have is why
don't we use good standard methods like
the qpcr
these methods are expensive and many
studies have shown that
if elisa is carried out under optimal
conditions
it could produce results that are
equivalent to those of the qpcr
secondly we hope to undertake image
analysis to provide uh
image analysis for root necrosis to
provide quantitative measures of the
necrotic lesions across the cassava root
uh we also hope to identify markers
associated to cbsd through genome-wide
association studies
and in the end we hope to understand the
fresher gene expression
when it comes to cbsd using rna-seq
so the triple sun the triple sandwich
the triple antibody elisa uses three ant
bodies
and this method is sensitive specific
reproducible
and affordable now it's important that
we develop such methods
uh we standardized touch methods like
elisa to
enable us understand the genetic
mechanism of cbsd
but it's also crucial that we start
selecting for low viruta in our breeding
programs
so selecting for low varicata means that
we will reduce
disease pressure which in turn will
throw will
slow cbsd epidemics and to a smaller
extent reduce the
chances of viral evolution currently
we are working with the cycle two
population of the ugandan breeding
program
we are working with about 450 clones
these are being evaluated in two
environments uh we hope to collect
tighter data at three
six and nine months after planting to
ensure that we study
about viral progression throughout the
grow the growing period
then while at 12 months after planting
we will use the root
uh to determine virata
using qpcr and also fta cards
so to summarize uh the elisa methodology
for the for the for the leaves we are
using
pulled leaves since we are working with
at plot basis not plant bases
and then we conduct elisa acids on these
leaves
and from this we look at the data as a
semi-quantitative and quantitative
analysis
then we generate the title and at 12
months after planting
we take the root and then
carry out qpcr to identify various
the viral species and also the
tita and this is also done with the fta
cards
so we'll still have varitita for the
root using two methods
now in the incident that the analyzer we
don't trust the results
from analyzer plate we have stored extra
samples as herbariums
so we could conduct simple random
sampling on the leaves
and make sure that we carry out qpcr on
those leaves
to confirm the viral title so the reason
why we are robustly looking at varieta
is that uh studies have shown that the
virus replicates and accum
and accumulates differently in the
leaves and the roots
so if we have to understand the
mechanism of cbsd
viral title we need to look at both
tissues carefully
so from viral tita we will be looking at
uh
root necrosis using image analysis we're
using the phenol apps in collaboration
with mercurial university
now it's important to know that truth
necrosis is the most devastating symptom
of cbsd
it affects the root which is of economic
importance to us
but surprisingly it's the least studied
symptom
because it's only evaluated once in the
growing season
that is at harvest so we think that
understanding root necrosis using image
analysis
will enable us classify necrotic
patterns
uh it will provide also quantitative
measures like the number the size and
the location of necrotic lesions
across the cassava root we also hope to
understand relationships between these
quantitative image
best necrotic measurements uh viraltita
and the one to five scoring scale
so at harvest the root uh the root is
the harvested root is uh sliced and
images are taken at the proxima the
middle and the distal part
of the root so this is an example
of images taken from one experiment in
one location
and you can see there is a difference
with necrotic expression
when across the root so sometimes
necrosis happens as a large necrotic
patch
sometimes uh they are very small
necrotic patches
sometimes it starts at the center
sometimes it's set at the edge and other
times it's just
random so we think that to explore
necrosis we will have to generate data
about the percentage of necrosis across
the root
the size of the lesions the number of
the lesions and the distribution
of the lesions so just progress on both
eliza work
and the root necrosis work is we've acid
uh
both traits in two uh two
regions that have uh that vary in
disease pressure
and we're currently processing the data
so the next objective will be to use all
these new phenotyping methods to find
genome equations
associated with cbsd by conducting
genome-wide association studies
now i'll talk about the next thing will
be to talk about just the trait
heritabilities from the recent
experiments that we have vested
uh it's good news to note that uh
most heritabilities range from moderate
to high
which actually means that the
variability that we are observing is due
to genetic differences
but the exciting thing about this this
powerpoint this slide for me
is the semi-quantitative elisa essay
heritabilities and the quantitative
elisa rc heritabilities
this is the first time we are we're
using we are studying this chart and the
heritabilities are good to work with
now when we look at the correlations of
uh the cbs the traits generated by the
one to five
uh scale and the quantitative assay you
can see these ones in blue
that range from moderate to high
correlation
positive correlation are generated by
the one to five scoring scale
but when you look at the
semi-quantitative uh
title and the quantitative title there's
a zero correlation between
these two and the traits that
are asset using the one to five scale so
now
this confirms our need to broaden the
phenotyping methods when it comes to
cbsd
and include varieta as an independent
trait so i will end here and i would
like to acknowledge uh
my committee that's headed by john look
michelle heck
and keith perry i would also love to
acknowledge uh jean luc and max sarah's
lab
dmz in germany and the best part
is the team in namulong uganda who have
helped carry out
my work headed by dr robert i now
welcome
questions
i think there's a question from mike
gore in the chat
if you can see that or i can read it
please read it i don't seem to find the
chat yeah mike says
is it possible to sequence the viruses
from fta cards to id
viral strains and study viral population
diversity and evolution across cycles of
genomic selection
this would help investigate how genomic
selection in the plant population
shapes the virus population the answer
is yes i think it's possible
and we will test it since this is the
first time we're using the fta cards
okay um it looks like we don't have any
more questions
okay just one more one if anybody has
feedback please
send me an email and i'll answer you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu